När du jobbar med att sälja produkter och maxa volymer, går det så bra att du kan sitta och räkna dina vinster?
Då kan du också ta ett ansvar.
Har du mer kan du dela med dig till de som har mindre.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så?
Nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har renda språk.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag så välkomnar vi Linda Häggqvist till podden som driver två olika bolag under varumärket Vangari.
Det får vi ta reda på sen.
Det ena är en studio som jobbar lite mer med PR och strategi och ett annat varumärke som säljer egentligen framförallt smycken med ett lite större syfte får man väl säga.
Så vi säger välkommen hit Linda.
Tack så hemskt mycket Joel, kul att vara här.
Tack, tack.
Vi har ju hållit på att försöka få igång våra datorer här igen.
Allting kraschade men nu är vi på tråden igen.
Precis, jag gänxar ju det genom att säga att jag hoppas att tekniken funkar men det ska man aldrig säga.
Men nu är vi på banan, nu kör vi.
Det känns tryggt här, vi får bara sitta en stund och glädja så att vi äntligen kan spela in.
Skulle inte du kunna ge mig en liten kort baseline om vem Linda är egentligen?
Vem Linda är, ja okej.
Jag har jobbat med varumärken, marknadskommunikation och strategiska samarbeten i hela mitt yrkesverksamma liv.
Det är ju länge nu, 20-25 år nästan.
De första nio åren var jag anställd och de senaste 14 åren har jag jobbat som entreprenör och företagsledare.
Jag bor i Ernskede utanför Stockholm, men jag är uppvuxen i Sundsvall och jag känner mig fortfarande som en norrlänning i hjärtat.
Och sen så, jag är ju 47 år gammal, jag har tre barn och försöker väl göra livet så rikt och innehållsrikt och upplevelsemässigt starkt som möjligt.
Det låter som en bra inställning till livet.
Det här som du pratar om med varumärke och liknande, när man har jobbat med det så pass länge, blir det till slut lite flummigt eller fastnar man lite i tankarna eller kan man liksom, orkar man bry sig om varumärken till slut?
Oj vilken bra fråga.
Nej men för mig blir det nästan tvärtom att det blir mindre och mindre flummigt.
För jag tror att man behöver lite erfarenhet och rutin eller en väldigt stark passion kring varumärken för att förstå potentialen och substansen.
Och nu blir det kanske lite nördigt direkt här men...
educationlandskapet är ju liksom så fragmenterat nu.
Så att varumärken lever ju också mycket sitt eget liv i sociala medier och genomförtjänade kanaler.
Så att jag kan känna att jag blir liksom mer och mer passionerad kring starka varumärken och berättelser och personerna där bakom, ju längre tiden går.
När måste man börja jobba i varumärke?
Oj oj Joel, nu blir det en utmaning direkt i vårat snack.
Alltså oj nu ska jag verkligen ta det här på voly.
Jag är inte helt säker på att man måste det.
Det är jättemånga som får sina bolag att flyga genom att bara jobba med produkt.
Sen är min personliga övertygelse att man kanske inte kan utveckla sitt bolag lika länge och lika med samma potential som om man tar ett omtag om varumärket också.
Men det andra svaret är ju, det börjar man med i samma stund som man liksom grundar sitt företag eller lanserar sin idé.
Jag fattar, vi ska inte nörda ner i den direkt utan jag tänker att vi går tillbaka till vad jag inte kan låta bli.
Men vi går tillbaka lite, du har egentligen två olika bolag, kan du inte berätta lite korta om två olika benen, och kanske lite hur mycket tid du lägger på varje och hur stora de är och motsvarande?
Jag vill inte vara jobbig med dig direkt här men det är inte två olika bolag, det ska jag vara väldigt noga med att säga.
Ja såklart, jag har kollat upp er så att det är absolut.
Det är ett bolag och det är två affärsområden.
Det ena affärsområdet är ett accessarvarumärke, ett hållbart accessarvarumärke som heter Vanguard i Stockholm, där vi egentligen designar, marknadsför och säljer smycken och andra accessarer.
Det andra är en studio, en kreativ studio som heter Vanguard i Studio.
Det är en PR-byrå i grunden.
Men så fort man säger byrå så blir folk så här, de är stora och de är trögrörliga.
Ibland säger vi att det är en PR-hubb eller en PR-startup.
Men vi heter Vanguard i Studio och det är då konsulttjänster.
För att svara på din fråga om hur mycket tid just nu som jag lägger på de olika affärsområdena, så skulle jag väl säga att 80 procent av tiden går till Vanguard i Studio.
Det vill säga B2B-verksamheten.
Och 20 procent åt Smyckesvarumärket.
Är Smyckesvarumärket mer liksom ett hjärteprojekt eller är det en riktig business?
Om du förstår vad jag menar.
Det beror på vem man frågar och hur man tittar på verksamheten.
Jag vet inte hur mycket jag ska hoppa in på bakgrunden nu.
Jag vill ha bakgrunden.
Jajamän, kör på.
Jag startade ju Vanguard i 2017 och det var ju efter en väldigt lång, jag gillar inte ordet karriär, men väldigt lång tid.
Varför gillar du inte ordet karriär?
Jag tycker att det kan låta lite pretentiöst.
Jag är inte uppvuxen i en sån miljö där man liksom, varken är en entreprenörsmiljö eller liksom folk med fina titlar.
Så när man pratar karriär kan det bli på något vis både självuppfyllande och självupplånande.
Jag tycker mer att den resa man gör genom livet, det är liksom, man måste toucha livets olika delar.
För mig att driva företag är inte en karriär.
Det är ett kall eller en mission eller målsättningar, men karriär låter lite utstuderat ibland.
Äkta norrländskt.
Var kommer du ifrån förresten?
Luleå.
Good to know.
Vid Van Garys uppstart så hade jag drivit ett annat bolag.
Också en kommunikationsbyrå i nio år.
Det grundade jag med två kollegor, två grabbar som vi satte igång 2009-2010.
Det var också en ren konsultverksamhet.
Det bolaget gick väldigt bra.
Vi dubblade våran omsättning år för år, de första åren.
Vi blev Gazelle, vi hade nordisk verksamhet, vi hade över femton anställda.
Det gick jättefort och jättebra.
När man kommer från en bakgrund som inte är entreprenörskretsare, jag kommer från en enkel, vanlig, underbar familj, då sa folk till mig, Linda, det här njuter man av, ni har någonting fantastiskt.
Ändå kunde inte jag känna efter de här sju åren att jag kände att allt är på plats.
Utan jag började känna en tomhet i det här med att jobba med reklam och kommunikation.
Jag kanske spelar in att jag hade fått mitt tredje barn där precis, och jag började se på världen på ett annat sätt.
Jag tror att man jobbar redan från början med meningsfulla grejer, man kanske är lärare eller man är polis.
Man jobbar med någonting som känns meningsfullt, då behöver man inte söka hela tiden.
Men för mig vart det väldigt mycket att vad ska jag göra med den kunskap som jag har samlat på mig?
Då kände jag att jag vill jobba mer med syfte som grund och försöka göra någonting av det samhällsengagemang som ändå alltid har funnits i mig.
2016-2017 snackade jag med min medgrundare och då sa han jag köper ut dig och driver bolaget vidare själv så du får följa din vision.
Så ja, 2017 föddes Vanguard.
Varför blev det två olika?
Jag tycker att vi skulle komma in på om smyckesdelen var lite mer passionerad eller ett hjärteprojekt.
Ja just det, det är bra att du vägleder där.
Nej men, då kan man väl säga att det från början så vad det här ideella engagemanget var mer på hobbynivå.
Det började med att det var 2016, 2017 så var jag vet inte hur mycket du följde det, men Syrienkriget och den krisen den var väldigt stor i media och man började titta på orättvisor och vad är egentligen riktiga problem.
Så startade jag en sån här dold Facebookgrupp.
Jag bjöd in 20 tjejer som jag kände.
Vi måste börja göra insamlingar för ideella organisationer.
Det var Rädda Barnen vi började med.
Vi måste hjälpas åt här, bjud in dem ni känner.
Så bjöd de in sina kompisar, vi blev 200, och de bjöd in sina.
Så till slut var vi 8000 kvinnor som satt och gjorde de här små insamlingsprojekten varje månad.
Vi samlade in pengar, vi samlade in hygienmaterial, vi samarbetade med folk som körde lastbilar ner till Syrien.
Det var så att det går att göra skillnad som en liten enkel människa om man samverkar.
Då tänkte jag att jag måste liksom, jag kan inte sitta bara på kvällar och helger och nätter och driva det här projektet.
Jag måste hitta ett sätt att göra det här till en affärsverksamhet.
Då tänkte jag att jag måste försöka bygga ett syftesdrivet varumärke i grunden.
Från början hade vi en tanke om att det skulle vara på en digital plattform, men ganska snart förstod vi att det behövs produkter, för produkter engagerar människor.
Vår första produkt under varumärket var Agar i Stockholm.
Det var verkligen inget hobbyprojekt utan det var så här, det här ska vi växa med.
Då började vi ta fram, det kan ju låta lite absurt nu i backspegeln, hur skulle vi få det här att flyga men det var Seed&Scarves.
Då kan man ju tänka, men Seed&Scarves och du som jobbar med e-handel, vad finns det för sökvolymer på det och hur mycket köper folk det?
Men vi var så insnöda på den här missionen, så att de här 90x90 cm Seed&Scarvesen, för oss blev det stora canvas att designa stories på.
Det var min lillebror som är artdirektor och konstnär som var med i uppstarten.
Han designade fantastiska motiv på de här Seed&Scarvesen, där vi berättade om utrotningshotade djur och vi berättade om samhällsproblem på ett vackert inspirerande sätt och sålde dem genom de här produkterna.
Nu kommer du att fråga mig hur mycket du sålde det?
Det var svårt, såklart, men det var också bra såhär i efterhand, för jag har aldrig drivit en e-handel förut.
Att börja med en produkt som var väldigt, väldigt smal, men som vi genuint kunde följa utvecklingen av, vi gjorde den här designen, vi letade leverantörer, vi testade så många olika leverantörer och vi fick hem produktprover som verkligen var top notch.
Då kände vi att vi kan börja sälja den här produkten, starta upp den här e-handeln och stå för vad det är vi försöker skapa.
Sedan var det som sagt en väldigt smal produkt, därmed en väldigt smal målgrupp.
Det blev också ett wake-up call när man kom från att jobba på byrå med varumärke och kommunikation, man har suttit i stora projektgrupper, man har haft team som jobbar med mediaplanering, medieköp, allting som man själv inte är superbra på.
Sedan var vi två personer som skulle få ett helt nytt varumärke att börja rulla.
Det var ju extremt påfrestande, men det var också väldigt utvecklande och lärande om man ska se det positivt.
Vart drar man gränsen någonstans när...
Jag tänker om man är...
Eftersom ni då blir ett varumärke som man står för någonting, då blir också sourcingen av material viktigt, och logistiken blir viktigt, och personalvillkoren blir viktigt.
Allting blir ju så...
Man kommer ju alltid bli synad i sin svagaste länk någonstans.
Vart drar man gränsen?
Vad blir liksom orimligt noga?
Det där är också en jättebra fråga.
För mig, om du pratar med mig som individ och företagsledare, så är ju gränsen vad vi kan stå för hela vägen ut.
Och när det kommer, om vi pratar om varumärket Stockholm, vad man gär i Stockholm i dess uppstart, så var ju det helt nya områden för mig.
Och för mig gällde det att kunna hitta och designa, tillverka och marknadsföra en produkt som inte gör mer skada än nytta.
Och att jobba med hundra procent silket till exempel, som är ett naturmaterial, det är nedbrytbart, när du återvinner behöver det inte sorteras, det finns inga dåliga material, utan det är verkligen naturmaterial.
Gravroniherden gjorde en så förmultnaden till slut.
Men vi tittade på leverantörer på den tiden, det här var 2017-2018, både i Italien och i Kina, som är silkets hemland.
Det är ursprunget.
För att produkterna i sig inte skulle kosta tre-fyra tusen kronor ut mot konsument, så valde vi en tillverkare i Kina.
Det är såklart, det är någonting som vi var beredda på att det här kommer att kritiseras.
Vi kommer att få stå till svars för det här valet av tillverkningskedja.
Men det hände faktiskt aldrig.
Jag vet inte om det kanske beror på att det just finns den här tajta symbiosen mellan silke och silkroad och Kina och ursprunget i den produkten.
Eller om det bara var att vi var så pass små på den tiden så vi inte rörde upp några åsikter.
Men det är ett exempel, ett svar på din fråga där.
Jag tänker på, du beskrev den här Facebookgruppen och du beskriver att, ja men ni vill göra detta på riktigt.
Jag upplever att ofta när man pratar med folk och sånt där så känns ju folk ganska engagerade.
Men om man kollar på företag så, absolut att alla har någon sorts grön agenda nu och hållbarhetsagenda, men det är ju rätt många företag som gör det för att de måste.
Det är lite bullshit på många håll.
Varför är det inte mycket större och varför går inte, om vi tar de stora lyxvaruhusen, varför pushar inte de detta som ett argument i varför man betalar mycket mer eller vad man står för som varumärke.
De som verkligen pushar varumärken.
Vad är det som gör att just social hållbarhet eller vad vi ska kalla det, eller kallade environmental grejer, vad är det som gör att företag ändå inte spelar ut det kortet mycket mer?
Men jag tror att det finns ett par olika förklaringar till det.
Dels tror jag att nu när du nämner, det var många frågor i änden, men du nämner liksom varumärken eller premiumvarumärken.
Och där tror jag att det handlar väldigt mycket om image.
För fast man tycker att ett varumärke har många olika touchpoints och marknadsföringskanaler mot sina målgrupper så handlar det fortfarande om att vara konsekvensringent och bygga någon form av image kring sitt varumärkesuniversum.
Och är du tillräckligt högt upp och tydlig i det så tror jag att premiumvärdena och imageen de går före.
Och det är också det som attraherar många konsumenter och många målgrupper.
Att få vara en del av någonting fint eller någonting flådigt, någonting luxury eller vad det är.
Så att vara solitt i sitt varumärkesarbete, det tror jag oavsett är key.
Det måste man vara.
Så det kan vara ett svar på din fråga.
Men går inte det lite hand i hand då?
Det har ju varit några sådana här skandaler där man har sett att de här varumärkena har barnarbetare eller det är dåliga villkor på fabriker.
Varför använder inte premiumvarumärken schyssta arbetsvillkor eller att man filmar från fabriker för att visa att det här är verkligen bra?
Det här är anledningen till att det är premium.
Jag tycker det är fascinerande.
Varför?
Nu vinner vi på ganska tunga frågor och kanske inte riktigt mitt område, men om jag skulle gissa...
Du kan mer än jag kan.
Men ändå, vi försöker uppfå ett resonemang där, så skulle det också kunna vara för att när du väl är inne på det fina hållbarhetsordet och du börjar röra det med ord som hållbarhet, sustainability eller responsibility, ofta är det då att du avkrävs resultat, effekt och 100 procent, att du ska vara on point på alla områden.
Medan om du inte ger dig ut för att ta det ansvaret, så avkrävs du nästan inte på något.
Så jag tänker att även om du gör 80 procent bra och börjar visa det, så kommer du fortfarande nagelfara, men vad är det som inte sitter?
Så det är en egen fundering till varför inte fler pratar om det.
Jag förstår, det blir lite farligt att gå in där, för då vet man att helt plötsligt innebär det ett helt annat åtagande.
Okej, jag köper det.
Det låter faktiskt som en ganska rimme, för det är ganska lätt att bortförklara det med att det blir dyrare, men produktionskostnaden kommer ändå att vara så pass låg för företaget, så det måste finnas en till aspekt.
Jag gillar den aspekten.
Det var en smart tanke, det vet vi inte såklart men jag gillar det.
Sen tror jag också att när det kommer till just social hållbarhet, och vi kanske pratar om socialt engagemang, det som så fint ibland kallas CSR, att man tar ett ansvar som företag, så tror jag att nästan alla företag idag har någon form av hållbarhetsprogram.
Om man inte startar en egen fond, så är det i alla fall att man i december varje år ger någon form av ett överskott till en ideell organisation, och så berättar man om det då.
Det tycker jag också att det är initiativ som ska premieras, det är jättebra.
Men det vi försöker göra är att säga att det handlar inte bara om donationerna, utan det handlar också om att skapa ringar på vattnet och få med sina intressenter i en form av, inte rörelse för det låter också så stort, men att man engagerar sig kring samma frågor och bygger då också relationer och engagemang kring de statement man väljer att ta.
Så att det inte bara blir de här pengarna i tysthet en gång om året.
Jag håller med, samtidigt vill jag ställa motfrågan också, varför ska företag ta det här ansvaret?
Mm, det är ju en jättebra fråga.
Man säger, till exempel, om jag startade ett, jag installerade vitvaror när jag var yngre.
Det var inte så att de som startade en vitvarubetik behövde ta ansvar för miljön, utan man åkte ut och installerade vitvaror.
Däremot, helt plötsligt när man har en e-handel så förväntas man ha en mycket mer, en större tanke bakom, men man startar ju ofta bara ett bolag för att man tycker det är kul att starta bolag.
När ska man helt plötsligt börja bry sig om allting och varför ska man göra det?
Det är en väldigt bra fråga.
Jag gillar att du manar till eftertanke där.
För att ta det vitvaruexemplet som du nämner nu.
Jobbar man med någonting som människor behöver, det är vitvaror eller det är flytvästar som man säljer.
Då är man ju redan, då löser man ju...
Jag förstår vart du är på väg, jag gillar det.
Men så fort du rör dig in i de här snabbväxande bolagen, eller det behöver inte ens vara det, det kan vara innan ens digitaliseringen, innan e-handeln också.
När du jobbar med att sälja produkter och maxa volymer, och sälja saker som egentligen bara breddar ett befintligt behov, så tycker jag också, går det så bra att du kan sitta och räkna dina vinster, då kan du också ta ett ansvar för att göra samhället lite bättre.
Det är min personlig åsikt, så har jag alltid tänkt, har du mer, kan du dela med dig till de som har mindre?
Jag gillar det, om inte din produkt i sig är en bidragande faktor till en bättre värld, så smidgar för människor, om det är en nice to have, då anser du att man har ett litet ansvar att hjälpa till på något annat sätt.
Är jag godkänd då, eller vi säljer ju gymutrustning, räknas det som en nice to have eller är det att vi hjälper människor?
Kan jag spela på att vi får människor att må bra och leva länge?
Kan jag bara skita i allt annat då?
Nej men alltså, igen.
Det är ju också inom företagsvärlden att folk pratar om att de tränar hela tiden, men jag tror på riktigt att fysiska utmaningar eller fysisk aktivitet är en förutsättning att inte bara få driva bolag utan för att vara människa.
För vi lever väldigt stilla sittande liv.
Där blir det som att träning ofta nu liksom, det är så mycket, ja men det är någon utseende hets eller så, men det handlar ju inte om det, utan det är ju vad människokroppen är gjord för, så du är clear out.
Yes.
Jag ska säga åt alla mina kollegor att det blir inga fler bonusar.
Det är ju ett social inbäckbolag i grunden.
Ja det är bra.
Vi kan gå in lite på Vanguardi Studio tycker jag.
Kan du beskriva lite mer vad ni faktiskt gör och lite mer vilka ni faktiskt jobbar med?
Ja men det är ju vår trygga hamn, det har jobbat med kommunikation och varumärkesutveckling och PR, återigen det är över 20 år nu.
Så när Vanguardi Stockholm tog tid och var svårt att driva upp så var det ganska lätt att snabbt aktivera vår konsultdel för att hjälpa både vårt eget varumärke men också andra varumärken att växa genom förtjänat utrymme, kreativitet och starka samarbeten.
Så egentligen är förenklat beskrivet så är Vanguardi Studio en syftesdriven liten modern PR-byrå som hjälper varumärken att få ut sina stories och sina varumärken genom olika kanaler.
Där sa vi redan från början när vi tog in våra första uppdrag att vi ska jobba med varumärken och företag och organisationer som vill göra världen lite bättre, åtminstone inte värre.
Så det är någonstans våran fina linje där, vad vi tar för uppdrag och vilka kunder vi jobbar med.
Är det en knepig kund att ha?
Jag tänker till exempel att om ni sitter där på ena sidan och någonstans verkligen bryr er om ett varumärke och de kommer till er och de har kanske inte det kapitalet eller den möjligheten att göra det som de borde göra.
Är det lite för lätt att ge dem saker gratis?
Det är väl det jag fiskar efter.
Jag förstår frågan.
Så fort du säger, uttalar att du jobbar med social impact eller syftesdrivet, då är det så lätt att det blir hjärtefrågor.
Men för mig är det här affärsverksamhet.
Vi kan jobba med att driva växande bolag och hjälpa företag att växa genom affärsmässiga samarbeten samtidigt som vi gör något bra.
Jag tror inte att det finns vattentataskott däremellan, utan för mig är det en symbios.
Vi jobbar ju med ganska många globala stora varumärken.
Sedan kan vi också kosta på oss att jobba med mindre företag och startups.
Men framför allt hjälper vi en del ideella organisationer.
Det är väl där de stora budgeterna inte finns.
Där är det vanligt att bjuda på tid eller kompetens eller samarbetsinitiativ just för att bidra till något bättre.
Det är en fin symbios mellan de olika delarna.
Vad innebär PR-arbetet, vad är det ni hjälper folk med?
När det kommer till PR, till skillnad från reklam, så handlar PR väldigt mycket om att få ut ett företags DNA och kunna maximera det obetalda reklamutrymmet.
Sedan flyter det där också ihop.
Men hjälpa ett företag att titta på vad ni har för tillgångar i er bolag, och era produkter och era verksamhetsberättelser som kan vara underlag att skriva om eller dela och engagera utan att vi köper en annonsplats.
Det stimulerar väldigt mycket, för man får jobba väldigt autentiskt med många typer av varumärken.
Naturligt attraherar vi många varumärken som också har som sin mission att göra världen lite bättre.
Då får vi sitta tillsammans med de här drivna entreprenörerna, marknadscheferna, varumärkesansvariga och titta vad finns det för nyhetsvärde, vad kan vi berätta om som attraherar dels media, men också till exempel influencers, eller det kan vara investerare, det kan vara andra samarbetspartners också, för att berätta lite längre historier än vad som kommer fram med en ren annons.
Kan du inte berätta om någon sån här kampanj eller historia, eller vad jag ska kalla det som ni har gjort, bara så att vi får en förståelse för hur det kan se ut?
Ja, men vi skulle väl kunna ta ett exempel.
Vi jobbar med det växtbaserade varumärket Oddly Good, även om du känner till dem.
Och det har vi gjort i lite mer än ett år nu.
För ungefär ett år sedan, början på 2024, så skulle de lansera en havredryck som var lite lättare än deras andra havredrycker och konkurrenternas havredrycker.
Då fick vi uppdrag, hur kan vi berätta om den här lanseringen på ett sätt som väcker uppmärksamhet utan att vi behöver köpa en massa annonser?
Då sa vi att vi skulle kunna titta på hur samhället ser ut och alla de här kraven på det som är platsannonser, vad som krävs för att få en anställning, hetsen i samhället på att vi hela tiden måste prestera.
Istället för att utlysa en ny tjänst så utlyste vi en 30 dagar lång betald coffee break om man gick in och sökte den här tjänsten när den här lättare havredrycken skulle lanseras.
Vi döpte det projektet till The 30 Day Coffee Break.
Vi hade genomslag i över tio länder, flera miljoner i räckvidd som då inte är betalt annonsutrymme.
I fredag vann vi faktiskt European Excellence Awards för årets låns nere i Berlin.
Det visar att vi är på rätt väg på något sätt.
Kul och grattis.
Vad vinner man när man vinner en sån där?
Får man nånting eller är det skryträttigheter eller blir man känd i branschen?
Vad händer liksom?
För en som har sagt att hon aldrig ska tävla inom branschtävling för att det är bara bla ha bla ha och det är bara en klubb för inbördesbeundrad.
Så kan jag väl säga att som liten aktör, när man har dragit igång någonting helt nytt och bestämt sig för att utmana jättarna, så det man vinner är ju då egentligen det vi jobbar med inom PR.
Man vinner andras validering.
Istället för att säga själv hela tiden, det här är bra det går, bra vi växer.
När någon annan delar ut ett pris eller lyfter oss i deras kanaler, så är det, det vet ju du också, det är ju tio gånger mer värt.
Så egentligen det man vinner är ju rekommendationer och kredibiliteten egentligen.
Och sen får man ju en fin statuett också, en anledning och fira.
Men som företagsledare är ju inte det.
Det är ju inte högst upp på agendan liksom.
Jag förstår.
Jag tänker att ni är ju som du säger rätt syftesdrivna och ni vill jobba med en viss sorts grejer eller företag.
Och någonstans är det ju så att det ändå är rätt många som spelar att de bryr sig om olika grejer.
Får ni många ansökningar eller kunder som du uppenbart märker att det här är ju inte på riktigt?
Hur tackar du nej till dem eller tackar du nej till dem?
Hur ser den processen ut?
Jag tycker ju sånt är väldigt spännande med hur man hanterar kunder man inte vill ha.
Det där vore ju intressant om det inte här var ett poddformat och frågade dig hur du hanterar den typen av frågor.
Vi bara skriker i telefonen, nej, så lägger vi på.
Är det inte så egentligen att det handlar om mycket inställningsfrågor?
Det kanske är att jag också är rå optimist i grunden, inte bara som företagsledare utan också individ, att man måste på något sätt försöka se the good.
Om ett företag skulle komma till oss och säga, vi har en kampanj här, den ska pågå i två månader och den ska stötta, vad hittar vi på nu för modeord, female empowerment, vi ska bygga starkare sig.
Då skulle det ändå vara ett fragment på att man faktiskt vill göra någonting bra.
Då skulle vi också tillsammans kunna förklara att det handlar inte om en eller två månaders initiativ eller att kränga så mycket varor som möjligt, för då gör ni ju bort det.
Det här måste ju vara långsiktiga, äkta, autentiska initiativ som vi kan utveckla, eller ni då kunden, kan utveckla över tid, oavsett om det är oss eller inte.
Jag tror att inställningen måste ändå vara att lite, lite, lite är bättre än ingenting.
Jag köper det.
Det kan ju appliceras på i princip 99,9% av alla fall.
Jag tänker att BP hade väl det här stora oljespillet, liksom om de hade kommit veckan efter och sagt nu vill vi göra en reklamkampanj om en Mås som flyger för att visa att vi är gröna, då kanske man får tacka dig liksom.
Okej, nu är du mycket tydligare.
Nej men det är klart det inte hade gått.
Och sen finns det ju liksom, för mig personligen, jag liksom, jag har aldrig rökt en cigaretti hela mitt liv.
Skulle det komma ett tobaksbolag och bara, vi vill ge bort jättemycket pengar till liksom, och satsa på unga kvinnors liksom psykiska välmående, samtidigt som man, alltså det hade ju inte gått, det är ju bara liksom no no.
Och ibland kan man ju...
Oftast är det inte så hårt kanske, men jag är exakt, jag fattar.
Jag tänker, du sa här vad som är trendigt just nu, så sa du female empowerment.
Kan ni se de här olika trenderna, och hur har det rört sig genom åren?
Nej men det är klart, det finns ju trender, och de är ju intressanta att följa.
Det har ju varit mycket, vad heter de, green energy, eller liksom man tittar på grön energi helt enkelt.
Och sen så female empowerment trenden kanske jag skulle säga, den har kanske klingat av lite grann.
Den hade ju sin peak för några år sedan.
Och sen så cirkularitet är ju nu också.
Det är ju liksom såklart, vad ska man säga, det är en trend kan man ju säga.
Men det är ju också riktiga entreprenörer som driver riktiga bolag, som vill lösa riktiga problem.
Så när vissa frågor kommer upp på agendan, så tycker jag också att det föder ju en innovationskraft och ett entreprenörskap som bottnar i att lösa riktiga autentiska problem.
Så jag vet inte om det är trender, men svängningar eller liksom, det är klart att det finns.
Ja exakt, det kan ju vara en trend, men sen kan det ju vara en större makrorörelse såklart som leder över tid.
Men exakt, vad tror du blir nästa stora trend som folk kommer hoppa på, om vi ska säga så, eller nästa stora rörelse som folk bryr sig om?
Oj du, alltså, nej men jag tycker att det är bara så intressant att följa hur saker och ting går i vågor.
Och att liksom någonting som rör upp väldigt mycket engagemang i ett par år, nästan sedan helt tystnar.
Och jag antar att det är liksom det naturliga sättet i någon form av evolution, att man kan inte alltid vara på alla frågor hela tiden.
Men mer specifikt än så, ja, nej, det är jättestor.
Vad tror du?
Ja, jag brukar säga, eller min flickvän brukar alltid säga att, du vet när man spelar frågesport och sånt där, så brukar hon säga att jag vill inte vara i Joelslag, för jag kan ingenting som inte har med gymkompaniiet att göra.
Jag kan ingenting om allmänbildning, jag kan ingenting om värden, jag kan ingenting om andra människor eller populärkultur eller ny...
Alltså jag är helt blank förutom gymkompaniiet, så jag har ingen aning, vad som helst.
Exakt, vi tar det därifrån.
Yes.
När du startade Wangari så hade du...
Hur säger du?
Säger du Wangari?
Ja, Wangari.
Halvvägs in i podden.
Då hade du med dig Sara, en delgrundare redan från start eller hur såg det ut?
Nej, så var det inte riktigt.
När jag startade så var ju...
Jag gillade väldigt mycket att...
Eller, vem gör inte det?
Men bygga team och komplettera det man själv inte kan med andra som är väldigt duktiga på det de gör.
Så det var min lillebror som var med.
Vi var de två första som startade Wangari AB 2017.
Han är art director och designer och han driver en framgångsrik e-handel idag.
Man får säga vilken e-handel han driver.
Ja, han är grum.
Jag har försökt få med honom i podden 18 gånger men han har tackat nej samtliga gånger.
Shoutout till Andreas här om du hörde detta.
Se fan till att ställa upp nu.
Det var vi i början.
Jag tror att jag kan tala för han också.
Vi är väldigt olika och det var det som gjorde våra styrkor då.
Men han hade också någon form av egen vision som inte hade klarnat för honom själv heller.
Det var mycket som förändrades i hans liv.
Han designade våra produkter, han gjorde vår e-handelsdesign där i starten.
Men ganska tidigt kände vi att våra drivkrafter går åt olika håll.
Det var väl egentligen brytpunkten när man insåg att nu behöver vi ta tag i det här, behöver gå tillbaks och inte vara förblindad på vad jag hade trott de två första åren, utan hur ska det se ut framåt.
Jag tror det var det som gjorde att det fanns ett momentum att kicka igång byråverksamheten, alltså B2B-verksamheten, parallellt med varumärket Vanguard i Stockholm, och få fart på det.
Jag ska säga, får vara helt transparent med dig också, nu låter det man morskar upp sig och bara, ja, det var ett tillfälle att satsa.
Men i själva verket så var ju vi då, när han lämnade, och vi bara egentligen hade brandet som inte sålde, det var några veckor från att Vanguard skulle inte finnas mer.
Det är lätt att säga också att som entreprenör, man är beredd att sälja huset för att få verksamheten att överleva.
Men när man väl sitter där och har några veckor av sina egna privata pengar och bolagets pengar kvar på kontot, då är man inte så kaxig.
Man har några barn också.
Ja, och de önskar sig julklappar.
För första gången på många många år känner man att hur kan mjölken vara så dyr?
Hur kan det kosta så mycket med ett SL-kort?
Förstår du vad jag menar?
På det allra mest transparanta sättet, att det här är en panikkänsla som det var länge sedan jag upplevde.
För man har riskat allt och allting är på väg att rinna i nuränderna.
Men då tror jag också att man får plocka fram den där kraften att säga okej men vad har jag för till?
Vad kan jag faktiskt göra?
Och vi hade ju den här planen på att dra igång byråverksamheten och verkligen sätta sig och vad säger de som är duktiga på sälj, nötalur eller liksom.
Så jag satt liksom en vecka dygnet runt i pyjamas och bara såhär ringde ringde ringde, boka maten, boka maten, boka maten.
Och sen så ja men det är klart vi kan testa och liksom ja vi känner ju dig Linda liksom, du kan göra det här uppdraget och så har man lite tur på vägen där och Men i princip var det, då var det bara du och då ringde du runt och så försökte sälja in typ konsultuppdrag för att få in pengar i bolaget.
Lite så tolkar jag det.
Får vara väldigt krasst och väldigt konkret så var det, men då tror jag också när man kopplar på den här sista energin, det här jävlar namnet, även om man ser ut som ett vrak och känner det här är liksom minuter från att det ska gå åt skogen.
Då tror jag också att det på något sätt är inte tur, utan då universum har en tendens att hjälpa en lite på vägen.
För då satt ju vi på det här, vi hade ju våra första skarvstånd, vi inte hade lyckats sålt via e-handeln.
Och så hade jag kontaktat, jag vet inte om du känner till, men H&M-koncernen hade ju ett, de la ju nyss ner, men det var ett varumärke som hette Afound, där de skulle hjälpa både entreprenörer och etablerade varumärken att sälja överlager.
Och jag hade approachat dem och sagt att vi har ett lager, väldigt fina, designade, svenskt designade sidens skarvs här, och hade haft några möten med dem.
Och tiden tickade på, han hörde inte av sig, och så ringde han mig några dagar innan jul, jag stod liksom på Gravturgatan där vi hade vårt kontor, och så ringde han och sa, man ringer inte en fredag utan att ha goda nyheter.
Och Foundo på den tiden hade två affärsmodeller, det ena var att de köper in över lagret och löser transaktionen, och det andra var att vi tar produkterna men ni får ta alla risk själva.
Och då sa han, det är klart vi satsar på er, vi tror på varumärket, vi tror på era produkter, vi gör det här inköpet.
Och då ringde jag min maka och bara, we made it!
Så jag stod liksom på grävturgatan, det snöregnade och grät och bara, vi kommer klara det.
Så det var väldigt härligt.
Ja jag förstår, fan vad skönt.
Man ska ha, det är ju inte tur men det är ju någon sorts procentuell möjlighet när man har ringt mycket, men lite tur ska man ha på dagen också.
Men hur gick detta till att bli en, vad ska jag kalla det då, quote on quote riktig PR-byrå sen?
Nej men då tror jag också, alltså det är ju varumärket Vanguard i Stockholm som är vår risk.
Det är någonting som inte jag har jobbat med tidigare, alltså e-handel och liksom, vad ska man säga, finansiering, budgetering för hela den kedjan.
Jag är ju duktig på varumärke och kommunikationsbiten egentligen.
Så att när vi började ta in uppdrag och lanserade Vanguard i studion och berättade att vi fanns och hjälper också andra varumärken med...
Men nu säger du vi, vilka är vi i den här...
Ja, just det.
Det var ju en del av frågan där hon sa det.
Nej men då, efter den där tiden du pratade om, när det började ta lite fart och man kände sig att nu har vi momentum, så var det precis innan pandemin där, årsskiftet 2019-2020, så utlyste jag då den första tjänsten, att vi behövde bli en till person.
Och Sara som du nämnde, hon var en av många sökande då och jag intervjuade henne och jag kände sig att det här är ju liksom, det är en perfect match.
Vi brinner för egentligen samma grundvärderingar, men vi är helt olika i vår dagliga operationella profil, om man säger så.
Och det är nästan fem år sedan nu.
Och från den dagen hon kom in, vi har gått igenom en pandemi tillsammans, vi har mött utmaningar men haft ännu mer medvind sedan dess.
Och idag är vi ju sju-åtta personer i teamet, även om inte alla jobbar heltid.
Så det är därför jag säger vi.
Och inte bara jag.
Är det bara du som äger bolaget eller blev hon delägare där också?
Inte direkt då.
För det tror jag är ganska, när man drar igång sitt livs andra bolag också, och när man möter någon för första gången, att inte bara slänga på utan känna först.
Från båda håll finns det nån substans i det här.
Men för tre år sen nästan så klev hon in som delägare.
Så nu är vi två som äger Vanguard.
Och vi har inget externt kapital eller externa finansiärer.
Hur var det att ta in en kollega på det sättet?
Magiskt.
Okej, det var roligt.
För min del, jag är kanske inte den här ensamma konsulten som tycker att jag kan allt, utan jag är väldigt dålig på väldigt mycket.
Så jag brinner väldigt mycket för den här underdog-känslan.
Att bara vi jobbar tillsammans med rätt personer som ett gäng, då kan vi klå vem som helst.
Jag är gammal handbollsspelare i grunden, jag tror verkligen på styrkan i ett lag.
Att hitta en person som man matchar så hand i handske med, jag vill inte jinxa nu fast det har gått så lång tid, men för mig är det ren eufori, att känna hur man kompletterar varandra och kan växa tillsammans.
Oavsett äldre, yngre, folk med olika bakgrunder, vi är ett jäkligt starkt team.
Hur hittar folk er och hur väljer man er?
Alltid när jag ska spela in en podd så går jag in och försöker backtracka folks liv i några dagar.
Jag har kollat upp er och framförallt om man kollar in er hemsida och liknande så är det inte jättemycket infor, det är inte så mycket case och det är inte så mycket...
Hur väljer man hit ska jag gå?
Då pratar du inte potentiellt medarbetare utan kanske kunder.
Kunder menar jag det.
Ja, men du har ju rätt i det, det är ju skomakarens barn.
Vi är ju relativt dåliga på att berätta om vad vi gör.
Vi försöker använda LinkedIn och försöker vara bättre men när man är så dinosaurig gammal som jag ändå har blivit och man har jobbat med ungefär samma saker så är det ju mycket kontakter.
Sen tror jag också att även om man känner folk sedan tidigare så finns det en skeptisism när man drar igång någonting från noll och det är därför det är så skönt med att det har gått sju år och att man börjar känna att tiden kommer i kappen och liksom nu kan vi äntligen börja växla upp i vår fulla potential.
Så att jag skulle säga 99% är ju gamla kontakter eller rekommendationer via nätverket.
Och sen är ju också, jag gillar ju att driva verksamheter framåt och utveckla affärer.
Men jag hatar att göra kalla kontakter eller kalla samtal.
Jag äcklas av mig själv när jag drar ett sånt här LinkedIn-mail och bara hej vi känner inte varansen tidigare.
Men alltså det är hemskt.
Men jag gör det ändå i väldigt liten utsträckning.
Jag får själv hat.
Men brukar det gå bra eller?
Nej, nej det går inte bra.
Alla som är duktiga på sälj säger att det där är en numbers game, du måste ta hundra kontakter, så får du fem ja.
Men det är självplågeri.
Men man måste ändå göra det för man vill ändå utöka sina nätverk.
Och jag vet att det finns automatiserade system och allt det där.
Men för mig handlar det inte i grund och botten om att kränga så mycket som möjligt.
Utan jag vill också få med det autentiska och genuina i engagemanget.
Ni jobbar ju, det är väldigt tydligt när du pratar, att du vill göra det här på erat sätt och det ska vara syftesdrivet och det går igenom hela grejen när jag gissar att hela byrån är på det sättet.
Och jag vet också att ni hade en del grundidéer när du startade bolaget.
Att ni skulle till exempel inte ta betalt i tid utan er resultat var en av de här stora.
Kan du inte, jag tänker att det är alla konsulters våta dröm någonstans att inte ta betalt i tid utan man vill ta betalt er resultat.
Jobbar ni så idag och hur får man igenom det mot kund?
Nu märks det att du gör din research men just det där vet jag inte riktigt var du har hittat det.
Det är ett gammalt LinkedIn-inlägg som du skrev.
Ja för att ta betalt i tid tror jag är alltid en del av ekvationen när man jobbar som konsult.
Sen är det såklart att om du har en kompetens, alltså till exempel en kreativitet eller en designfunktion eller vad det må vara, ett system kan det ju vara.
Då kan du inte bara ta betalt i tid utan då är det också värdet alla de år och all den erfarenhet och kompetens som sitter i den leveransen.
Men sen vet jag att det finns PR-byråer som inte tar betalt i förväg utan de säger att vi tar betalt i effekt, i räckvidd eller i genomslag.
Men det kanske är lite grann som att du skulle säga när du monterar ett gym att du kommer bara ta betalt för det här, om den kundens kunder blir seoså mycket starkare och det är upp till dem också vad de puttar in och helheten.
Så jag tillhör inte en av dem som säger att bara ta betalt i effekt.
Jag förstår, jag förstår, för jävligt där, jag får läsa på ännu bättre nästa gång.
Jag tänker när ni sitter i de här mötena, jag tycker alltid det är väldigt intressant med kreativa yrken.
Jag jobbar ju någonstans med väldigt konkreta produkter.
Men när man jobbar med kreativitet eller fantasi eller att tänka ut saker, vad gör man om man inte levererar?
Om det inte blir bra?
Den där frågan kanske jag har svårast att relatera till av allt du har frågat nu.
Det är alltid bra.
Jag tänker att oavsett om man jobbar med gym eller man driver någon digital startup eller jobbar med kreativitet, att stanna vid det inte känns...
Det är ju aldrig slutet för någon som driver bolag.
Förstår du vad jag menar?
Ja men jag fattar vad du menar.
Jag gillar det.
Om det inte känns bra i magen, då fortsätter man lite till.
Jag vet inte hur du är funkat men för min del är det i alla fall att det här med att driva bolag kanske också är lite självbevalsedrift.
För min hjärna, nu kanske jag blottar med det, det här kanske jag inte har hemma i den här podden, men det är ju aldrig stilla.
Det är ju liksom ett ständigt pågående brus.
Jag brukar fråga min man eller mina kompisar, har ni tusen tankar om, nej, nej det har vi inte.
Så just det här med att ha ett yrke där man också får utlopp för en hjärna som hela tiden jobbar, det tror jag är en del av att känna sig nyfiken på livet och uppfylld som människa eller vad fan som helst.
Så lite ego är ju också fast man bygger större och större team.
Eller kan du relatera?
Jo, men jag gillar det.
Jag gillar det att slutpunkten inte är där i så fall.
Jag tycker om det.
Sen tänker jag, den här kreativiteten som du pratar om, eller de här tankarna i huvudet som du nämner att de inte slutar, betyder det att du tycker att kreativitet är någonting som man är född med, eller är det någonting som du utvecklar under tiden?
Är det någonting som kommer sluta, eller som blir grått och stagnerad?
Eller hur funkar det där om jag vill bli mer tänkande?
Hur ska jag ta mig till?
Jag tror att det är ganska svårt att läsa sig till.
Någon form av självhjälpsbok, liksom så blir jag mer kreativ.
För jag tror, som du säger, det finns vissa människor som är född med det, precis som man är duktig på bollsporter, eller jättetalang på sång eller nånting.
Men jag tror att alla kan utveckla sin kreativitet.
För mig, när jag jobbar med teamet och vi jobbar med både äldre och yngre talanger, så är det att inte jämföra kreativa förmågor, för kreativitet är dynamiskt.
Det kan vara en kommentar i ett möte från en person som har varit hos oss i tre veckor, som är förlösande för hela lösningen, för projektet.
Jag vill ju se kreativitet som totalt obegränsad, men du behöver vara i ett sammanhang där den tas tillvara på.
Hur fungerar du som ledare i det sammanhanget där du har ett antal människor som ska vara kreativa?
Du måste ändå skilja sig litegrann från så som jag har det där, driver lager.
Det finns säkert kreativa aspekter i det också, men för mig så handlar det väldigt mycket om, och där är man ju drillad i en bra miljö från första gången som jag satt i fötterna i arbetslivet, att alla idéer är bra idéer.
För 20 år sen jobbade jag med jätteduktiga kreatörer som i kreativa möten till exempel, så finns det inga nej eller det finns inte såhär, men det är för dyrt, du vet, som man annars kan göra om man liksom har hela skopet i en business.
Så att bara bygga en miljö som är utmanande, som är trygg, men som också är modig.
Det handlar inte om att nöja sig, men jag tror att utan en grundtrygg miljö så vågar inte folk heller riskera och bjussa på sina tankar.
De tror att det här kanske är lätt dumt eller det här kanske inte passar.
Bara försöka ta bort allt sånt, utan det här är en totalt trygg miljö och spotta ur sig sina förbättringsförslag.
Det kan ju vara en process i ett lager också, det behöver inte handla om en reklamkampanj.
Kreativitet finns ju liksom överallt hela tiden.
Det är lugnt, vi behöver inte jämställa.
Det är helt okej.
Jag vet att mina killar på lagret inte tar illa upp om de inte blir jämförda.
Kreativt i Stockholmsbyrå.
Hur gör du för att de...
Och missförstå mig det, nu är jag från landet.
Hur gör man för att en grupp flumbullar ska hålla eyes on target och liksom ändå vara konkreta i det man gör?
Men jag är också från landet, eller även de som är från landet.
Det är därför jag tänker att jag får ett bra svar nu.
Ja, ett gäng flumbullar, eller vad du sa.
Det är liksom den bästa förutsättningen för att skapa en kultur där man på riktigt känner att vi hjälper varandra.
För jag tror jobbar du med ett gäng elitister, inget ont om liksom folk som har varit i prestigersfyllda miljöer.
Det är också viktigt, liksom man drar varandra.
Men ett gäng flumvullar som känner att vi har någonting på gång.
Jag tror att den kapaciteten och den utvecklingspotentialen, den är oändlig.
Så jag tror bara det handlar om att bygga en miljö där man känner sig som ett vi.
Sen gillar kanske inte jag det här resonemanget som var för några år sedan, att så här, laget framför jaget.
För det tror jag också är att missa lite kapacitet.
Så vi pratar väldigt mycket om jaget för laget.
Så att alla får ha sina udda unikiteter och olikheter, men ändå fokusera på teamets bästa idé.
Tycker det var kul?
Ja, jag gillar det svaret så jag känner att jag pausar av det.
Jag försöker alltid pausa på ett bra svar.
Jag säger ett stort, stort, stort tack för att du var med i podden Linda och vad skönt att vi lyckades lösa teknologin till slut.
Tack för ett jättehörligt samtal.
Plumbullar.
Plumbullar eller vad du sa?